Ok, we move into June, let's get our indicator set back up for the 1500th time
at this point,
make sure that everything's on point,
inputs, I already know at the back of my hand now, this is 11 to 2,
this is zero to four, this is six to nine,
and it's UTC minus four, not five before we start making mistakes. Cool,
indicator set up, we are indeed bullish, so we're looking for longs and let's
begin.
So starting straight off of the tray, it looks like.
That's a shift, let me make sure that my one minute struck to at one point.
I'm pretty much looking at this, stops at the lows, profit target,
I'm always going 1% current balance.
You know we didn't check, news.
Third of June, we have ISM, so we don't have anything for London,
tag day and I'm going to tag it up. Did I join all the previous trades?
This is a London sweet friend,
this is a weak point of interest,
it's obviously London, trend is
confined reversal, structure flows, void, premium discount,
nope, news, execution window, three to four,
we got tagged in and out with the same candle, sometimes that's just how the
game goes.
There's another re-entry here, nope,
possibly, nope, that's five, right?
Okay, with some bullish. Okay, so what do we have here? We have
a reversal, so we have the low sweep, a sweep London, reversal, we would need
to see New York
pull back and continue, nope, do we have news, London 3rd of June, we have ISM
at 10,
it's technically a break, the problem is, I'm not a huge fan of the area,
because this is the area that makes the trade,
but the problem is like this, that's the entry, but there's the problem of like
a still see that liquidity, even though technically it's a still liquidity set
in there,
in an ideal world when I take a trade, I want to take a trade that's based off
of prices trading
lower, it will shift market structure and then I want to trade the leg that
shifted it, I don't
like trading, for example, this, right, I can deal with if we have, for example
, like,
if we have like this, for example, we shift and then we break and then I trade
this,
but when it's like this, I just, not a huge fan of it, and trading that,
and then this entire leg is open, I don't like that, but from a model
perspective, again, we can
come back and kind of, if it's not tradable, I guess we can come back and
look at this, if I do take this trade, I'll make a note, I'll be totally honest
with you,
I don't think I take this trade in the live market, like in fact, I'm almost
certain that I wouldn't
take this trade, I like the target though, to solid target, I'll make a note of
it because,
like I said, I don't take this in the live market, I just don't, and there's
also like,
it's such a rare occurrence as well, and an ideal world price doesn't tag me in
,
I'll move a stop, that's very huge.
It's 9.50, ISM is about to be released.
I don't like that trade, I'll be so real.
I don't like that trade at all, I don't even like using that as a trade that
adds to the data
because that's just not a trade that I'm going to take.
Is it valid? Is it the setup? Yes.
Am I, am I being irrational because it doesn't look nice
to conclude my judgment on something that I don't have the data of, kind of in
some sense.
Again, I want to be very clear about something here.
Do not confuse this as here's a point of interest, price is bearish in the one
minute time frame,
we come in, we shift, I put my order on here, the one minute trades higher,
we have a free kind of public on the one minute and it trades higher and then
moving your entry
to here. Please do not confuse this for this because this is not this,
so a completely different thing. I'm always keeping my order on here,
even if the one minute shifts bearish to tag me into my position.
That's fine, don't confuse that for this.
What this is, it's a specific setup variant, that is we have London Low
and London has given this type of price action and then we hit Lull,
which is the session between London and New York and what happens is price
trades below London
in that level and then we have a reversal in that same window and then New York
session starts
here and so this is kind of what happens. Now what has happened is London, New
York needs
to have a break of structure, right, which is a continuation for this to be a
valid setup.
That's what this is, so don't confuse it for the prior.
Well, we're also well above 5R, my first profit target would have been
5R and this is like 7R.
I don't know if I take this in the life market, this is something I can really
come back to
at the end and have a clear and something like, I'm going to close 50% of the
position here.
I don't like that.
It's like 7, 12, 3, 6, 9, that ends up being like a 9% trade and it's a trade
that
I don't think is a high probability setup and it's traded and held
through ISM. In those scenarios, I don't mind holding a position as well, by
the way,
through a moderately impactful news event, as long as my stops are as long as
number one,
your prop thumb admits it, so your prop thumb actually allows you to do that
and your stops are
already at or slightly above break even because if price does tag in, you might
get a little bit
slippage if you stop here, for example, you might get a little bit slippage but
you might
take a very minuscule loss or you might just literally get attacked out of
break even versus
it could go in the other direction and you could gain off the momentum and so
it's kind of for me
if you're in a position that's for the name profit that is also aligned with
obviously bias
and whatnot and you have a clear liquidity target like this, for example, I don
't mind holding a
trade for the news, that's not the problem. The problem isn't holding a trade
for moderate news,
it's one of the tag factors. The problem is, is that I don't like the entry
because
I would prefer not to have my stop loss here, I prefer to have my stop loss
here, for example,
right or like a worst case scenario of my stop loss to be like
here and that doesn't give the risk of water so we have that trade but honestly
I'm not a huge fan
of it and like the problem here is that I can't even tag it as discretion
because it isn't discretion
but I want to pay close attention to
to that specific trade and how it impacts the data. So that trade is a law
continuation
that is where the law sweeps London, we reverse in London and New York gives
the continuation.
At the end of the testing we want to pay close attention
to this trade and see if this trade skews the data because let's say for
example I come back
at the end and oh great this trade, this setup is profitable, right? It
returned 3% but one of
the trades was 7% gainer and the other trades will all lose us like I don't
want that to influence
me using this specific setup because again I don't care about the data here, I
care about
the data when I'm getting to the real market. Cool, so I see this is a broad
point of interest.
I see it as obviously New York session. The trend is
confirm reversal, obviously everything is on point like from a trade
perspective it is the right
trade, don't get me wrong, I just don't like the entry and then add on the fact
that we hold
through a relatively impactful news event. I don't just don't want it to skew
my data.
The internal trend is counter, premium discount,
I think so.
Yeah, news held through other news execution window.
We do execute an hour before news. Again that's okay, I assume.
Cool, keep moving, that's not spent too much time on this one specific.
So you notice as well I haven't none of this back tested or model have been
predicated
around anything higher time frame target wise whereas the old ones were, this
is just way more
repeatable and systematic and better win rate as well. So yeah, again
experimentally you want
the entire premise of this is you knowing how to trade like an operator not
just like some guy
like oh give me a magic strategy that works and then I'll start making money.
It's like you might
but what's even better is if you can actually be a trader. Cool, so you can
obviously see we
were on the right side of the market obviously. Okay, let's move on.
My swing lowers all the way down here.
Wait, 4th of June. Damn we just spent like 30 minutes in the first four days of
June.
Okay let's speed things up.
I don't know if there's a single set up there, unless I've missed it.
I have missed it.
And sometimes you might see me make this mistake, it's just because I'm trying
to get through
pretty quick and read the price action but I'll always come back and make sure.
There's a trade here
that ends up taking a stop loss.
Obviously pretty simple with bullish. We're way below age ascension low
but we're basically trading a full in life but it's it's neither here or there.
you
don't lose out on your day or collection.
Nope.
I have jokes at 10.
Okay that mean we haven't luck here.
Shift below, then New York opens we should perish.
That's not a braid.
I should perish.
That's two candles.
Okay
the prices take the high.
Now we have jolts in around about 15 minutes.
And there's jolts, boom.
And don't mind it. So we respected this level.
That's technically a shift but I wouldn't open my trade.
That close to jolts, never in a million years I would open my trade.
That close to a red news ever.
An hour before, sure, I have time to get break even.
I just haven't taken partials, maybe my trade idea even completes.
Open them a trade two minutes before.
No, I don't care if it goes in my direction, just no.
What's up, brush?
It's a crazy attempt.
It is technically a trade.
That's technically a break even.
This is still traded out.
Just not mitigated as it is.
No, it is mitigated as well.
Price trades out, we come back and we mitigate where our entry is.
We're traded out of here, we'll even order a block.
We'll come back and see what a block we mitigated.
And then we'll continue to expand out.
There's no reason for price to come back to break even.
And let's break it.
That's fine.
Does it help us?
Yes.
Again, quality risk management.
And all of our trade management is just purely predicated on our understanding
of price.
Pub and period.
There's an unpoint.
Transtrending, right?
Sink it as period discount.
I'll make sure for sure, but...
It is.
My anticipation is that this low has taken out.
Fail to produce a reaction.
Hold on a second.
I've gone to the different day.
Unintentionally, I was there.
Let's just make sure I miss anything.
Neo session comes in.
Wednesday the 5th of June.
We have ISM at 10.
I'm obviously looking for longs.
Is there a confirmation in here?
Damn.
Those are completely accidental.
Okay, although I'm not a big fan of this trade.
What do we have?
Equal lows.
Don't like them.
The model's the model.
We're bullish.
We've had a sweep of London lows.
In this sweep, we see we have no shift.
We come in here.
We're putting three candles to buy side.
This is the lowest candle here.
One bullish candle, two bullish candles.
Three, four, lows.
Break.
That's a high.
That's the...
That's the point where price breaks.
This is the low of the point price breaks.
Let me get my words out.
It's the M15.
What's the PIP size?
3.8.
Basically the entire trade range.
The actual end goal is up here.
I don't think price gets up here.
But...
That's why along the way I want to make sure they have targets.
That's why I want to make sure they have targets.
Just see what happens. Didn't mean to skip that far.
I meant to skip to New York session.
To this New York session.
Not to the next New York session.
I don't know why did that.
That's the tag.
That's also like range.
This is also a game.
Accumulation.
Manipulation.
Distribution.
This entire range is the real area that we're looking at.
So this is why when price comes back in,
it comes back into this range.
So this is a 15-minute order block.
We also have we have ISM 5th of June.
Yeah, ISM at 10.
I'm going to close half of the position at 5.0.
I closed that previous one a little bit higher than 5.0.
So I'm going to close this one a little bit lower than the effort target,
which should even it around properly.
It's going to be 50% of the remaining target.
And then obviously the rest of the position
will leave legs to run to this house.
Because again, I'm betting mainly on the intraday volatility.
That's what these models are built off of.
That's why they're built off of sweeps of sessions and reversals.
Because they're built on intraday volatility.
They're built on price running to a liquidity pocket.
And then reversing from that liquidity pocket.
The next day is somewhat of a new volatility, a new intraday cycle.
But we leave partials on to these swing highs
because we understand that that's where price could go.
But I'm interested in taking partials as many as these intraday highs as
possible,
because those are the real money makers.
That's why you see we get tagged up break even for ISM.
One day ISM tagged with break even.
One day ISM rung into your profit level.
But also again, really good trade management.
I was expecting that these lows get taken anyway.
Like even just trading from them.
I expect those lows to be taken.
I have everything.
New York is really performed.
New York has been doing a lot of work on this.